foreign
Caleb is up next in Chattanooga
Tennessee Caleb welcome to the show
hey guys thanks for taking my call
what's going on
well I'm having some
Financial struggle with my girlfriend
um
really like I'm I'm doing all right
myself we have separate bank account
um you know I've never really thought of
combining them or anything but she just
hasn't been handling her finances very
well
and it's kind of putting like a real
strain on our relationship
in what way
what's your involvement with her her
money
she hasn't been able to help out with
any of like the bills we live together
ah there it is okay so a lot of combined
bills she can't pay the bills
no like she she can hardly even pay her
own bills
why and
is she working full-time yeah
yes and no
um
[Music]
that that was the issue like she took a
job that didn't really pan out and so
for about a month or two there she
really didn't have the income coming
coming in
okay and
you know on top of that she didn't
really have any money saved up to fall
back on so she was putting stuff on
credit cards
so you're are you covering all the bills
right now
yeah like so brother was like the
household belt Caleb is the problem
Financial or is the problem you're
growing increasingly
disgusted it's probably a strong word
but you're growing increasingly
frustrated by the character of the
person you're trying to play house with
yeah I mean I don't want to like you're
are you starting to believe like I don't
know if I want to be married to someone
who rolls like this
yeah I mean that's definitely I think
you kind of hit the nail on the head
right there okay because here's the deal
one George and I are both going to tell
you if if you're not married and we can
say there's a moral issue fine but
there's there's a legal issue if you're
not married
paying each other's Bill playing House
playing each other's bills it just makes
for a mess dude if you own a house
together the whole thing is just so
complex
and so we would tell you man If You're
Gonna Play House get married and because
at least there is some legal protection
as you separate things out if things go
sideways if you're just dating it just
turns into world war three and four and
five but beyond that
man both George and I are married we
both are all in on on the woman that we
are with and if there's a season where
we gotta do extra that's what I mean
there's no problem there that doesn't
seem to be your issue that seems to be
like you're just getting increasingly
frustrated that this is who I'm dating
this is a
like come on and she's just like yeah
you got it is that right
yeah I mean that's definitely
you're going down the right right hole
there I mean what what kind of
frustrates me is
I feel like a pressure like she wants
the our relationships to move to like
the next level what is the next level
you guys are already living
that would be like marriage or kids ah
and I'm not comfortable doing that with
her because of her finances have you
told her no hey hold on it's not because
of her finances
it's because of her character
they are expressing themselves in her
finances
don't get those two screwed up because
she's going to make you a bunch of
promises and say okay well I'll pay my
credit card off and I'll go get another
job that's not going to cure the
underlying which is I'll do whatever I
want I don't have to participate in
building make creating a home together
and also in her defense
I y'all are kind of just making up there
I mean you're just it's very wishy-washy
and it's hard to it's hard to Anchor
into wishy-washy right
yeah yeah I agree
have you had a conversation with her yet
about all this
yeah I I have and it just ends in like
arguments and yelling and stuff I'm I'm
just kind of at my width end because
as even as we speak like she's getting
like opening up new credit cards account
card accounts and stuff like that have
you have you said to her have you said
to her
being in debt scares me to death
and when you borrow money I can't
breathe
and moving forward in my home the home
that I want to raise kids in and build a
family with
we are going to be people who don't
borrow money and so if that's the way
you want to get through your world I
love that you are opting out of
relationship with me
have you said that
no I haven't have a backbone man you got
to stand up and speak your virtues out
into the world
because you're gonna wake up three years
from now you're gonna have two kids
you're gonna be considering a wedding
and you are not even gonna know what day
it is you're gonna be so frustrated
is that fair
yeah I would never listen to me don't go
tell me hey I called these guys on the
radio they told me to dump your butt
that's not what we're saying at all I'm
telling you the only thing in the world
you can control is your thoughts and
your actions so you go be a person of
character and say exactly what you need
and what you feel
and then she gets to opt into that and
y'all create a life together or she gets
to opt out of that and have a bunch of
shiny plastic toys
that's it
I know I made that sound real simple I
know it's super way more complex than
that but Caleb this is this is eating
you alive man this is turning into
resentment this is turning into you
feeling like you're enabling her poor
decisions and if I'm in your shoes I
just go this relationship isn't working
our values are too dissimilar for this
to work and I wish you the best and you
know what that means someone's got to
move out and it's gonna get real awkward
real quick
because your first thought's gonna be
like I've been paying the bills and
she's gonna say bye Felicia and the
whole then the whole thing starts over
the whole thing then George and I high
five and we're like told you so but but
we won't do that I know the next few
steps are gonna be real hard but what's
even harder is just sticking this out
hoping things change and it just gets
worse and then you've got a lot of
resentment and uh John deloney uh he he
quotes another super smart psychologist
guy who said choose guilt over
resentment yeah and you're gonna feel
guilty You're Gonna Go ah she's already
going to a tough time I can't believe I
could do this to her but man it's gonna
choose that over hating
the woman that you you love right or
hating your mother-in-law or hating your
dad like choose guilt choose the
boundaries right
um and it goes back to
um
I don't think I'm a lot of talked about
it yet but I think I've talked about a
little bit um it's a secret well it's
just like I got a new book coming out
and in the fall and but one of the
discussions
um comes from the great Michael Easter
which like you gotta it's hard it's life
is hard if you are overweight by 100
pounds it's hard
and it's so hard to lose 100 pounds so
you're not toggling between oh one's
real easy and one's real hard my life is
super simple if I'm 100 pounds
overweight and my knees hurt my back
hurts and I'm exhausted and like it's
it's not you're not choosing between a
real fun time and a hard time losing
weight they're both hard
right now what he's choosing is nobody
taught that dude how to say his needs
out loud and nobody taught him how to
build a sit down with somebody and build
a picture of what marriage could look
like for us and building a life and a
home together no one's done that doing
that will be almost impossible and
living with somebody that you don't
share their values and they are just
digging a hole that expect you to clean
up
that's hard too so it's not an easy
one's easy and one's hard they're both
hard you got to just choose your
Hardware one One's Gonna Leave lead to
Freedom what's the path that's right
that's a good word One path heads Heads
to Freedom man wishing you the best man